okay
this does not look like morning i did
sleep till morning what is that
a poop bug that might be a cookbook
we never got a uh used a crossbow can we
no
we need like 18 decks damn we never got
like a monocle
nope coats
scarlet
rock i just picked that up yeah
i'm gonna use it
yeah so
i'm not sure where exactly is taking you
back to you this is the start of the
town
which um
what that guy asked us to do hey i
totally think we need to beat that
yeah and then i'm guessing he's gonna
give us something that will make this
town
oh yeah we get the needle yeah
yeah i think dogs to the left
yeah dog's up there yeah
so like that's i saw him right there
like that head
do you have a name
no
how do i get
up oh damn it
when his eyes going like that that
street tool is cool yeah what is the
curve
oh my god um it's you just have to be at
the right spot and you just press r1
you know like lock in
oh one
is
um
yeah
yeah
i realize i play
mostly xbox but i used codes yeah for
playstation
i'm coming for you doggy
seriously i know i did that before too i
was like
oh you could examine it
i'm going again
you you got the painting
i guess oh why oh maybe we hang it in
the oh god
at least they keep to themselves yeah
damn it
what are you trying to do sprint oh
you're just hitting the wrong button
that's probably the entry back to the oh
big bug
big bug butt
eating
what did nothing happen
dude what
i inclined to disagree
no the video game is wrong
strange maybe it appeared inside the
tree or something oh maybe that's
possible did it take you
are you back in the swamp right now
yeah i think you're in the center of the
swamp
oh god yeah
let's go fight that dog
you can also
try to find the golden needle and then
go back to the dog because it's right
there
this room's so cold without the warmth
of jacob i know
caleb
yeah that's where you are
what a beautiful morning what a
beautiful house
in the morning oh god
up there
there
oh
there yes going up there
oh it's a giant skull where's this guy
no
get out of here ghost skill
thanks for liking my activity on xbox i
really should tell those notifications
off
every time i'm like
and i love that it's just a default
windows sound effect
i don't love it
i just kind of noticed it those are
eagles weird thing to be a fan we can
there's no
fall damage with the horse right i don't
think so
um
well
wait doesn't the horse have double jump
or is that something you unlock i think
that may be unlockable
well so there is fall damage there is
certain damage yep but at least now
you're back to
right where the wolf is
there is double jump oh you do have it
yeah
that's some general grievous i have a
feeling
this might not be the case but i have a
feeling
if you double jump right before you hit
the ground it will negate
sometimes
so there's a needle in a haystack
have we been there
no because it said no get me off of this
yeah showing you because like we didn't
even see it we just saw the whisk yeah
directions only apply when you haven't
been there
that giant tree
i have been there yet but i didn't
explore any but thoroughly
just the right amount of junk
no it didn't let me double jump unless i
like hit the
wall or something
just trying to find a needle out here
man yeah needle in a swamp stack pretty
much
i keep turning as well like i'm not i'm
losing sense of my direction
uh i think i know you are oh there's
another one
and another one
and another one
they really are frequent huh
oh where is it guiding us
that's it's pointing that way right
yeah what are the ones on the left of
the map doing
interesting
that's strange
i feel like that
well it's i think it's just pointing us
yeah
that one is pointing you
towards
i think it maybe it's regional like it
knows this is the question yeah
it's pointing us towards the town or
something or the
dude in the shack
another one that's so frequent
oh another grace yeah
yeah that is weird
they're right next to each other
huh that's very strange yeah it's kind
of suspicious maybe this is an area in
which death
is frequent
[ __ ] you oh it's one of those bug dudes
again [ __ ] off [ __ ] how [ __ ] dude
i still think you could
you could go kill
i
will
[Music]
jacob's dropping a fat deuce
yeah jacobs
for those of you wondering where jacob
is he died
for a long time
at least
i think at least 11. yeah that's
probably fit
which way
this
oh
sneeze
even he sneezes all that good
no it's all bug people [ __ ] people
oh but they're like on the ground
yeah little few waffles
this doesn't look good it's so dark i
need a torch oh gross it's just a
cinnamon waffle
yeah essentially
it's like a donut and waffle ball have
you ever had those uh
oh my god
oh my god
how many of them are where are they
coming from where are they shooting from
it's so dark this is creepy
no
oh
no
oh
damn it we're it's
two hits takes them down to like five
percent
okay they identify themselves
yeah
hey hello
at least they're not as strong as the
other days the ones with legs yeah lots
of legs
because technically they do have all
have legs please don't use them
i i've been playing maternal so i look
down at the bottom right to see if there
are any uh what happens
enemies
yeah okay they're all gone having
crossover games with your hands
crossover games with uh dark souls or
any from soft game is dangerous messes
up all your buttons yeah i keep trying
to play light seafood there you go
chester being here
oh there's a little little dungeon he's
gonna teleport us again why are you
trying to eat jacob he's gonna give you
a lick
meteoric or blade
[Music]
it's pretty oh it's cool johnny
do you wanna want the last one
yes please there you go it's a big one
[Music]
that's the big chunk
have you ever had the cinnamon toast
eggos yeah i used to have those a lot
when i was a kid that's what those are
like
because they're not good yeah they're
terrible you love them when you're a
child
before you have like real waffles
they're like microwavable waffles right
it's a toasted toast yeah ah you
probably toast oh that's cool yeah you
can put them in the microwave if you're
like a lunatic i guess
[Music]
a test
oh is it you made it daytime
no it just became daytime okay that
looks like a flower enemy that looks
like a hopefully right
oh it's a stone
what's that
i just punched it i did no damage to it
though it like got a little upset yeah
since this is open world so
directionless right now yeah well since
it's open world all i want to do is just
explore and run past yeah don't do it
these enemies are going to come oh lots
of magic man they just talk about you oh
look out for that who's doing that
what is up here there's what's the
reason the thing up here this is man
with hats we just need a second to just
slow down down
you got pickups
oh god they got the spears like that oh
no it's like that spicy butt from that
chip oh yeah you still got spicy poops
yeah
[Music]
oh
that's the worst
so it was that swamp we were running
around in previously that's where the
needle is correct to find it yeah
[Music]
braces it's possible she needs to go off
oh okay
maybe why she's stressing at me
oh what's that sound
oh
oh yeah did we ever find out what was
causing this it was just a natural
phenomenal yeah i think it's like
i control this we got yet
yeah cool
whoa look at the size of that one
big boy
oh
it attacks
we saw one earlier and it didn't drop
anything
oh huh
but it was like up against a wall like
this so we thought maybe it glitched
oh
cruising is really in teardrop scarabs
oh
a replenished flask so the red one was
this a blue one or a red one
i didn't look
it's red okay so you get your classic
but we already had full flash um well we
learned a lesson
lesson we learned a game a lid
what is
this yes oh those are those enemies that
we saw before remember we saw one
worming around in the field yeah
oh that's moving
it's damaging
yeah it looks like it's all gone though
it's just a ball
i'm gonna make you rob [ __ ] oh you coat
your blade
[ __ ] okay
so get it before it sprays
we got bounce dude it's got faces all
over
it is the
oh god it does have faces
all right all right
yep
easy peasy
it's guarding something too
yeah this seems like
i'm gonna release some evil spirit or
something yeah it's an egg
sombra's gripping stone five of them how
about that
oh
galenti oh clint's done firefly i saw
the beginning and end of the name
glitzy
what is why is it so dark
i don't have a torch right i don't think
so we can buy one usually you can buy
one from santa probably
now i'm kind of like i know when i play
this i'm going to be squeezing in some
intelligence in case i find it oh my god
oh yeah
that was always the case with like the
uh
those like moonlight swords it's like
this is the coolest sword you've ever
seen but you've been putting all your
points in strength huh
oh they got something there too
they become worm
oh
it's electrode cool
oh [ __ ] there's zigzagging all around oh
yeah look they reassembled
he's gonna do it again he's building up
oh
christ i did not see that
they definitely look very innocuous
until
it's too late
should i do some jump ropes
oh boy
nice nice nice get out of there oh geez
oh
oh my god
is alana yelling something from outside
this is yelling at the dog to pee
oh somebody's dying oh by the way there
is fall damage with the horse okay good
to know
okay somewhere in here is a golden media
what about that tower there
this one
streets of sage's ruins yes
oh never mind doesn't go anywhere it's
just a
stone tower
i guess look for the glint of items or
something unless we have to kill
something
to get them well i don't see anything
special
oh what's this
toxic mushrooms
oh
did it force you off your horse no okay
oh look at that
nice it
come on mimic
rock sling a spell
oh baby
rocks from the earth and sends it flying
pretty straight forward
read the war oh
i thought you just give me a look
yeah
one of the glintstone sources that
manipulates gravitational forces
pulls a clump of rocks
from the earth and sends them flying
this sorcery can be cast while emotional
you see a gravitational technique
studied by the young rattahan
his master was an alabaster lord with
skin of stone whoa
george rr martin loves those stone skins
thanks george hey
whoa we tried to follow you down here
that wizard they're trying to gas you
out
yeah your mushroom man
this is my house he is a mushroom man
what yeah he's just got like a oh
uh it's a whole last of us situation
oh hey
but one of them boys
like he's starting to change his mind
oh
all right
you guys got me last time oh there's the
muck that does something to you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
did you see a zip around the corner oh
that's gonna build up
scarlet rot
what is that i don't know but your
health is going down
so it's just another form of poison it's
like worse poison
it's like toxic i guess yeah
it's so weird on top of poison yeah so
they can exist
you know we found the thing in the hole
we found the little we got the spell
worth it
i want to find this needle
it's out here somewhere the red swamp do
you think it's really a needle
uh it's got to be just like an item
it might be a metaphorical
oh
so it's a needle yeah so it might
actually be a straight up needle
all right maybe these ruins somewhere oh
there's an item
you double jump with the horse yeah cool
these flowers out of here
flowers oh let's call the rock
don't worry i'm okay yeah
you're right
magic
[Music]
sorceries and incantations
cool
running around with the sword and
establishment sounds so cool okay yeah
yeah
i wonder if it's like skyrim yeah
you don't need
like is the staff just
yeah you do
damn that was so cool
yeah if there was just weapons equipped
with spells yeah other than needing
stats
how homey they are yeah that came back
real fast
oh i have a drink
the shrine is like right here that's
good
have yourself food
that's the rock comes on
still if you're on the horse
if you're out
yeah
no i think it it someone's stuck on me
or something you are a little gassy oh
there's the poop
guy
yeah all right where to next
because we haven't explored all of the
swamp not quite yet yeah maybe we just
leave this area keep looking around
that needle's out there somewhere where
the hell is alana everyone's on her
channel
being like who are these two [ __ ]
well your cracks hanging out come on
jacob oh a little show
little show for everybody like who are
these two
hot boys
this is a good framing for a let's play
too it's like are super wide yeah
there's a big gap in the middle
oh you're right yeah you don't hit the
rod on the horse
something is like
starting to really cast a spell on you
or something
oh
oh what was it sacramental blood
what the hell is that was that a winged
knight i think the big flower shoots the
lasers
yeah it's pretty sick pretty sick pretty
[ __ ] sick dude
nice
skyrim up the cliff
oh
yes
there's so many different areas
it's just every time you move it
brings up a new name so you went in
there and that's where all the stone
balls were okay
so let's just keep going around the
edges what are the big knot of roots
over there that's what i was thinking
yeah that looks ominous we gotta find a
boss and that kind of seems like it's in
the middle
yeah oh oh oh i heard a noise yeah let's
do let's do a loop yeah and then we'll
go to the big pile of roots yeah
okay i think this might be where we came
in
oh
oh
magical oh another one of these eh
magical spa please
a mystery
to be solved
i was saying that maybe if we were on a
horse it wouldn't follow the route yeah
but it kind of seems like maybe it is
yeah still
it's is a more complicated loop it's
going good we're just exploring the
swamp looking for a needle it seems like
it's not following the oh no it is it
might just be a really long
how does one know
everyone in the comments was asking for
you sorry guys they're about to thanks
thanks for the gifted sub to dickwade69
dick love gross
i said lord oh the accent that dang
accent
69.
yeah another one of those we followed it
like a few loots
it was really cold when i went down
freezing i think it was behind you
i don't want backstage john doesn't have
the food
my hands smell like churros
yeah
so many bugs
[Music]
making a dog wait 15 minutes every time
you want to feed them does feel very
cruel but it's the rules it's the
medicine yeah you're the human
yeah oh
wait this is just the biggest back to
dog okay go back to dog
so there's way up somewhere for sure
i think we might have been going towards
it uh i think it's when we found the
poison peeps that's what they did
we went the other way yeah this works
look at that when you found the point i
mean it definitely says in the swamp how
big is the small region because i'm
taking it literally as though it's like
in the water
can you go
yeah overlooking the swamp
well we're technically in this one
yeah so the swamp i think is this watery
that always face right yeah right
oh
all right maybe you have to go all the
way around this big cliff here and go up
the other side yeah so this is where we
started going up
but then i forgot
and then you just left
but you when you're in california you
know that is doing something
it's wind maybe it's just a spear on the
ground and there's physics or something
look at this cool guy
oh he's got two bows
he's the grievous of bows oh god
you don't want to be the grievousness
back through that gate is probably dog
again right
what the hell did that i have oh maybe
obviously i'm throwing that big pot i
think that might be higher
that gay oh maybe yeah
let's get up there let's get up there
after a rest did not meet us
you would know based on what other prom
soft games do
if he says it's in the swamp
does he mean literally the location that
says swamp
yeah everybody's so esoteric it's
probably just like this vicinity the
swamp yeah the idea of the swamp he's in
the concept of a swamp what does george
r.r martin think of swansea
that's what you need to find out
so celia gateway is where t-rex is
under stairs like ghost boys that we
can't fight y'all
dang ghosts
so it's down here oh it is down here
that's the liquid swamp
yeah but i think this is the one because
that was where we found multiple like
right next to each other
yes we're
playing it's up there
so we go wait what the [ __ ]
does anybody see
yeah let's get up on the rooftops
[Music]
let's pick one
the one that we were heading the one
with the gate that we
i think it's that
oh oh donkey
santa again
the
we have so much money
do you have a torch my friend
okay helps the scarlet rot no thank you
i'll look
oh look
so it's basically all
these useful things
that's interesting you can actually sell
stuff
yeah what have we to sell
goods you want four cookeries
i don't know what that is oh i wonder if
you can sell
oh well it you could sorry what were you
saying yeah i only know the cookies are
because emil and halo reach wears one um
yeah you died so yeah those
those little golden rules to break them
that makes sense sell for the same
wait okay why did i sell those we're not
near
[ __ ]
it was the demonstration well they're
not that far away
yeah
i forget what we look like when the sun
hits your face
you know
just a whole different being
all right let's just find somewhere cool
to go
i want to know where the [ __ ] that
place that we're heading right before
and they got bombed can we see it is it
that one or is it that over there there
are a lot of towers that look like that
yeah
[Music]
all strength no decks all right for now
because
it's uh it's a thing you're right that
the strength will help us with mom's
written at least
yeah once we start topping out on
strength
yeah
we'll diversify
where are my souls this way
is it that tower
yeah yeah yeah um
i wonder evil plants if it's just fun
like aesthetics
or if the rain
affects things
what is that little
red square that you have
[Music]
yeah well we're heading towards our
souls i think we're on the right level
for it yeah dang it
that dang scarlet rot is going to be a
problem oh look at the merchandise
hey
you're the merchant yeah we just scarlet
rot stuff
zombie scarlet rod
uh we're probably gonna run out of gills
but maybe oops
just just ride fast make it maybe we'll
find a grace like inside the gate show
us
here i go there's that guy up there he's
waiting for you big ruffles there's a
giant skull in luke yeah yeah that's
super awesome no oh
why did you keep doing that i thought i
was gonna flash oh god
all right now ride
ride for the gate
this is just dog
oh what's the point i've been saying
it's just dog okay well maybe we get up
to him yeah maybe he has needle
oh you're gonna die drink drink drink i
don't feel like the needle is probably
in the small because that's what he said
i feel like we explored it all there it
is
that's your answer
should it be nice
is that grievous again yeah that's great
oh no that's yeah did we have no souls
did you even pick him yeah i picked it
up
yeah
yeah we just don't have one here let's
go to santa let's see if okay
so he used to teleport from bonfires
yeah
yeah yeah
okay so maybe we can actually i bet you
it's in there although i felt like we
explored that whole place no i think
that's where the
[ __ ] are who will kill you and
i think that he'll give you an item to
let you
no no the the ghost man
that's in cellular
sorcery okay let's
wait runs
where's santa this is a pretty sizable
map yeah dude yeah it's chunky
and it's only
it's very little of it i think
there's also like big dungeons and stuff
too so all the things that are
underground or inside of them like a
mini boss in one of the dungeons
i don't know what was to find
do you sell
a torch you do oh
how do you feel about coopery
that sounds pretty cool
just two torches sound cool all right
there's our torch right there
beautiful
i wonder if the rock stuff is maybe like
in dark souls through the worms or
something where you take the torch out
oh it'll go away yeah maybe not probably
not it's a fan i'm an idiot sorry
it's possible
i feel like maybe the torches are sorry
the um like what are you
regional like that they're heading you
in a direction that you
need to go in based on the area you're
in yeah
those are definitely pointing somewhere
they're all pointing up
yes to the north i'm going to that
castle on the island okay
okay yeah that's what that's how i roll
you roll how you roll can you set my
points you have to try
thanks
yes
oh is it just a little
i think if you place a beacon if you go
back and place a beacon you can actually
you can see it if you place a beacon
press a
that will totally work yes actually yeah
that's good
multiple beacons
oh look that's cool oh you see it in the
sky yeah that's what i mean oh that's
dude i wish it was like that in breath
of the wild
rather than you have to take out your
[ __ ] telescope yeah yeah or your
little switch chica slate
it's just a switch
this is the canyon that has a rot in it
it's these flowers it's the flowers
they're kind of sexy though they are the
way they open that's like all flowers
are sexy
like not 100 but not far off yeah it
depends how thick that stamen is you
know what i'm saying
that's what me and my homies say all the
time what is that
that's what
it's not
i'm getting paranoid now when everyone
was
oh that
i think maybe there's another one like
right above our head
i'm glad you pointed that out because
that would have scared the [ __ ] yeah
they're sure it's appeared out of
nowhere big dumb head small body
oh [ __ ] yeah it's like it's like a
different face of the scene you should
ride directly underneath it i will after
this
i think your alarm's going off
downstairs oh is it
doo doo doo doo oh yeah
it is
dragon communion
do gesture it'll take you to a secret
area
yeah
dragon stance yeah
nice
so cool
lana
i got a thumbnail for you okay
is it me and jacob screaming
i can wait for the last one
i need to find a good wall
yeah yeah that stone wall over there
look at the fossils cookbook
awesome
you can make some nice uh nice stuff
label cobbler
oh [ __ ]
look how crooked that chin tattoo is
oh no it'll break the whole game i don't
understand it's going to turn the webcam
we'll off it later
yeah it's a good look
so we stumbled across the dragon
communion ruins
i remember that dragon that feels like
it was days ago yeah
[Music]
whoa
what do we need to buy dragon hearts we
have to kill dragons
oh my god you'll kill my dragon
is so [ __ ] sick how are you gonna
pick between dragon ball dragon claw
oh [ __ ]
dude no no
dude you kill the dragon can you tell us
about it we talked for a second yeah
at
it's because i want to carry you so bad
okay but a man you'll hit him one day
oh yeah
guys
oh
watch this
uh-huh oh careful no that was good
oh
well at least we're
right our bonfire is right there yeah
you can take this i want to parry this
dude
you can do it
that's always my stubborn rules i have
to carry every enemy i understand i
understand i'm a reluctant parrier
what are those russian walking houses
called
like the baba yaga yeah
you got the chicken legs
so he was over
he was just rolling in here he's walking
around he's over here would be right
where you are
let's get those runes back
quit reminding me that there's a pointer
pointing directly where i was
i like being lost it could be worth
putting a marker down for where that
dragon fire was so that when we get
dragon hot we can know to go back to it
oh it's it's at the it's i think the
bonfire is called cathedral dragon
that's convenient easy to remember
so we're going an opposite loop to find
there he is
a [ __ ]
i'm aware that i shouldn't give her
attention as much because um it's not
good
[Music]
but it's bad for you right you're first
is [ __ ] he has arts he's doing the
demand
it
actual [ __ ]
yeah he looked at a new move
right at the last second he knows i'm
gonna [ __ ] him up
oh wait you put your shield away somehow
he's got a couple new moves that he's
using right now the dodge district
he's that he's not using his sword yeah
he's just hitting you with this yeah
what the [ __ ]
hi can you go excuse me
just
play oh he squatted down for that one
he was just like
oh
god christ
oh
john i just think maybe we go to the
castle i think you could parry
yeah you can parry i need a perium you
need a pair go 15 minutes it's fine
i only need 14. yeah you one one for
perry there it goes get him in the ass
come on cramble
it's cramble now
you're alive oh my god oh my god
is that the first time he went
two-handed
oh
oh
dude he's really cool he's very cool i
want him for that i want to dress like
him
this guy's like a black knight or
something yes
there you go yeah yeah i can just spam
it but i don't want to oh
my god
oh and one flourish
oh he's tea bagging you're still going
oh he looks sick i got this that's
[ __ ] cool
i wish the crinkle looks like that no
craig was perfect
maybe he'll drop his clothes and i can
wear them yeah that's why it's worth it
he drops the clothes if you carry him
every time that is fighting or is like
shall i defeat you night i shall strip
the clothes from your body
so cool
his storm stomp is
use your wild strikes it's teaching you
empathy john that's how enemies feel
about you
tangle storm stomp is legendary
oh this
the wild strikes have no poise damage oh
yeah he was just like ah
i'm still going to finish my swing
all right we got you guys there you go
that's the one this is the one we got
this yeah it doesn't really matter if
you beat him he's got a pairing you got
this we're going to parry and then we
can leave just run away
you carry him i'm going home
do you think that we're ready to go back
to mongrel you have to find jacob
obviously it's up to you man maybe we
would level up that strength maybe
hunger i still want to know what's up
with the [ __ ] needle
we should find the needle i'll just like
one of our quests
it is a [ __ ] dude
i was trying to switch to two-handed
there we go here we go repair fairy
that's different
all right in the butt
okay now switch to two-handed and charge
it up
[ __ ]
he's got a big shield
what are you doing
nice jumping strike
hi
that's basically a parry backstab yeah
did you do it
yeah he's dead
what is going on
do you need to wonder if he just went
you might have to fight him again
yeah
your face
i am also here
yeah
where are we i'm like the elder ring of
dogs you see
what was the name of the
souls boys character whiffer perry
i will parry you here we go perry coming
up
good thing he's got a little shot you
got come on come here okay
you can make it you can make it come on
oh no get that butt through there there
we go
come in here my friend ah into perry
town oh [ __ ] up
oh it was a wall oh i thought that was
gonna get you
sorry
i'm going too late i feel like then
harry only died the perry timing is
different maybe it's not i think it is
probably isn't it maybe i'd have to go
earlier better you do have to go faster
than you think you need it definitely
felt different than dark souls yeah
it is not a dark soul no it is not it is
ringing
it is george r.r martin
you really can tell you just look at it
why do you do
it's like he's learning he knows the one
thing that you can't i just want to pair
him once
you can do it look at that look at this
i'm going to pair him once and then he's
going to immediately kill me it's fine
as long as you carry him it doesn't
matter
yeah you've won you've won this fight i
have i haven't yes so he can't he can't
win even if he beats you it doesn't
count
squat for me
yes
ah deeper
just made me hold her hand oh
is that what she's doing back there yes
oh sweet girl
i want to find one of those bone desks
into the firearm
what
that thing is we need to switch back to
the storm stones don't talk real good
think we're ready to kill the dragon
oh yeah yeah for sure oh for sure for
sure all right hold on i have an idea we
got three more strengths okay i have an
idea
this is a good idea
you powering on horse
leaving is it leaf oh i love that this
is a good idea
that's great can you do like the jump
off a cliff and then do the second jump
right let's try it because
oh look a big dog
who's dog
oh a very big dog oh i've heard about
crow
there are many big dogs
oh my
i think crow is the left oh boy
[Laughter]
okay
um what is going on here
i think as long as you go fast you'll be
fine that one's scary
oh look there's a little house on a
tower over there
this is freaky i don't like this
no small ones
fan daggers i don't know
yes
all their legs are misshapen so they
can't move very fast
hey guys
that's uh that's really scary oh
one of these
a bunch of burnt corpses oh nights it's
like
the vibes are bad down here john
leap
anybody seen a golden needle
please oh that's a great kid touch grass
that's the grass
you're breathing on my elbow
it's like just it's stimulation trying
to keep you warm we'll get that grass
i'm easily distracted stop breathing and
i'm bad at focus
is there anything in that building right
there
well the house on top this one yeah next
to the grass this this one right here
yeah oh look there's a ladder next to
the grass yeah
are you a grooves or a grass man what
are those shields
those are people
shoes oh man i wish there was a kick
yeah that could be we don't actually
know that there is we've not looked well
they're not so tough yeah you still like
exposed nice
nice [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] real game of
[ __ ] there john yeah
that's embarrassing there isn't a
controller
yeah they don't show you the controls
there's no right keep going
again
one more time and there's one more there
you go
i don't see any kit
i don't know
i wonder
let's try this dude
up here
she's so they're slim and old yet so
muscular you know i'm so hairy
oh god
who said they could have grenades
[Laughter]
i also incorrectly assumed there was a
wall
right there
look at that guy
he's like where'd he come from
what happened i have an idea okay
uh i like these ideas yeah yeah well
this one's different okay
okay
i was thinking that unequipped maybe
there's a different uh maybe there's a
kick
maybe you have to have both hands for
you
nice tragic good heavy attack
oh actually hold on
they slid down
[Music]
just said kick where oh
what is it it's so two-handed unhanded
unarmed it's your skill basically that
makes sense ah
all right that's all you need
oh baby
and
kick
it does not
throw them as much as previous
i love that sometimes good to just hit
was there anything actually up there any
treasure chests or anything i think so
okay it was like a little
guard station
look at that look how cool
oh my god the red sky dude the whole
video game just the whole thing
all right i have four minutes
i'm gonna find this tower
did you go take it out and get to that
castle yeah and get the grace there
dude
hand it off to jacob
he was immediately going to leave and
not explore the castle
i think i'll explore the castle i want
to carry on john's legacy
yeah we've already fought margaret
before
wow
oh [ __ ] dude we got him
wow
she's hot it's a hot statue all right
you got this john
it's okay if i don't
pay attention to that i apologize
it's just hot she's so cute
i think my
what what
also i don't think that other dude died
from falling oh he's so much sure
he doesn't want to find the ladder
though yeah you could deal with it so
heavy yeah we definitely won't forget
about it
if they'll get killed when we go yeah
definitely not
hello
you should try rolling through
everything yeah you should kill
everybody in this room
that guy was sleeping oh yeah there's a
treasure oh yeah
you you you
you you drink oh
oh
they did indeed find him
oh my god
all right back up the tower back up that
tower you want that treasure don't come
you need to chill out you need to chill
out she's here to help we're also we're
all we're high energy and stuff that's
what it means
she's like it's a fun time
i should be part of the flight times to
be involved
[Music]
oh
they punch up your butt
nice
this is like the three stooges
oh
no the most vocal we've ever followed
yeah
which is getting your butt slapped yeah
nice just keep going keep going
keep going oh nice that's nice
first try first try
i like how i think i need to go for that
thief first yeah that's a question
[Music]
oh christ
you try this just see what it's doing
today
oh
okay it takes a little bit to walk oh
you were fine that took stamina when you
liked that you see that yeah
oh hey guys oh [ __ ] they just got down
too oh boy my god wow they really this
is good
this is helpful yeah this is what i
meant to do oh we made a mistake
careful step through that wall
no i didn't need to do this
nice nice nice nice nice oh cool
yeah i can't believe you did that
without ever failing you know i think it
was the glute stone scraps that
it adds blood and stuff i think that's
new yeah yeah i know like i've noticed i
killed an animal and it like splattered
blood across the ground it was awesome
in the direction of the swing i for some
reason had not been paying attention to
that and there's another
is that a trifles
right on the wall yeah
there's a sting tablet
talismans previously were
for
magic
magic
yeah talisman is like a faith-based
where is it
agent
talismans raises attack
all right start
climbing
there's a house up here
okay okay never mind there's nothing up
here
oh my god
they're our eyes
disappeared it is raining through the
roof oh maybe that's actually why that
could be um programmed that way that if
there's a bunch of blood it'll rain to
wash it away so it doesn't have to sink
at all there's still some blood it's
pretty nice
guess what's back here
what did you want me to look at